Hablamos de invenciones e innovación
como si las mejores cosas del mercado
fueran Internet, las tabletas
o los teléfonos inteligentes.
O quizá, sencillamente,
los trenes, los aviones y los autos.
¿Cuál es el más importante,
el mejor, o el más fabuloso?
¿Cuál ha tenido el mayor impacto social?
Hoy en día el debate probablemente estaría
en favor de la tecnología informática,
pero, ¿lo está?
Algunos dirán: "No, en verdad no,
es la agricultura".
¿En dónde estaríamos si no existiera?
¿Se rinden?
Seguiríamos cazando y recolectando
con muy poco tiempo para inventar algo,
entonces ni pensemos en Internet.
Así es, la agricultura
es la semilla de la civilización.
No es literal, pero sin
el descubrimiento temprano
del uso de las semillas
para cosechar los granos,
no tendríamos mucho
de lo que tenemos hoy.
La siembra de nuestro propio
alimento cambió todo.
De acuerdo, la cacería
y la recolección funcionaron bien
por decenas de miles de años,
pero no pudimos hacer mucho más;
no hubo tiempo.
Pero cuando los cazadores y recolectores
empezaron a sembrar semillas,
comenzaron a cultivar.
Con el cultivo llegaron
los animales de granja
y con ellos se dio el asentamiento
y el sedentarismo.
Entonces, ¿qué tiene esto que ver
con la invención y la innovación?
Todo.
Quien alguna vez haya cultivado,
así haya sembrado seis matas de tomates
en el patio trasero de su casa,
sabe que, por lo general,
se cosecha mucho más
de lo que se puede comer,
hay un excedente.
La agricultura produce
comida en abundancia,
suficiente para almacenar,
comerciar y comer.
Dicho de otra forma, no todos
necesitaron ser agricultores.
Esto le permitió a otras personas,
no dedicadas a la agricultura,
hacer otras cosas
como herramientas,
alfarería,
y casas.
La agricultura y los excedentes de comida
propiciaron la división del trabajo.
Esto aún sucedía hace miles de años,
la vida no era fácil;
pero con tantas personas
colaborando en la comunidad,
las aldeas pequeñas
empezaron a desarrollarse.
Conforme aumentaba la
población de estas aldeas
crecían también las necesidades
básicas de las personas.
Las cosas se complicaron;
pero la civilización es justo eso:
sociedades avanzadas y complejas.
Y sin la agricultura
estas sociedades no existirían.
Las aldeas aumentaron de tamaño
y con el tiempo se convirtieron
en las primeras ciudades.
Las ciudades son sólo una característica
básica de la civilización;
otras características son:
un gobierno central,
un sistema de escritura,
una religión organizada,
arte y arquitectura,
el planeamiento urbano de carreteras,
puentes y obras públicas,
clases sociales
y empleos diferentes.
Lograr la pericia en diferentes
tipos de ocupaciones
permitió que se idearan formas
innovadoras de hacer las cosas
produciendo nuevos artículos
o que se hicieran avances en tecnología.
Conforme aumentó la complejidad
de las civilizaciones
se necesitaron nuevas
maneras de hacer las cosas.
Algunas se lograron por necesidad
y otras porque la gente se las ideó.
El compartir de ideas y tecnología
produjo el auge de las cosas
que estamos prestos a usar hoy,
como Internet.
Por eso, sin la agricultura,
todavía estaríamos cazando y recolectando.
No habría ni videos,
ni computadoras
y, por supuesto, no existiría
la red mundial, Internet.